you stumbled upon an opportunity I can
make you rich rich enough to impress a
princess what would I have to do there's
a Cave of Wonders
bring me the land
I tell you my favorite line in the FEL
sure yeah
my Sultan your highness he's not who he
seems he is
tell me about filming that night the
story yeah it was a really intense
moment a very dramatic scene and I think
I had had a few long days and I came in
and just completely fumbled the line and
will will not let it go I think I said
something like he Munim whom seemed him
is really how it came out it did come
like that and then I just we couldn't
stop laughing and and we'll actually got
it made into t-shirts as a wrap gift so
do you ever wear it I do I do it is my
it's part of my pajamas yeah it's a bit
that's what you do with a t-shirt you
don't like you know no kidding I can't
worry it out because no people would be
like what is that if I could grant you
wish and you could insert yourself
either as Aladdin or yourself into one
of your favorite movies a classic movie
what film would you put yourself in
maybe inglorious basterds by Quentin
Tarantino that's one of my favorite
films of all time so and the character
working that is amazing so I'd love to
do that what happened if Aladdin went
into his past that would be a little
weird that would be a little weird we'd
have to make sure it up a little bit
your dance moves in this movie are
pretty off the charts thanks thanks so
what is the is there a dance move that
you didn't have previously that you
think is your signature move now of lots
but the the Harvest Festival dance the
one that's I do with Naomi and we face
each other and we do it I would say that
one yeah yeah you know the hands go up
like this and there's a whole sequence
to it so you still have it you still
have it down yeah I think so I think so
and if I could grant you another wish
when you go to the movies and you go to
the concession stand
yes what would you like to see there
that you don't currently have uh lots
cuz I'm vegan I'm plant fast and there's
never any vegan candy so there are these
vegan M&Ms basically that I love that I
would love to see them to see in stores
you need to bring it out I don't blue
and you can they are they are it's a
packaging actually it's a blue packaging
it's perfect you I know when you and I
only first lock eyes in this movie
that's when I knew it was on oh thanks
so did you were there a lot of takes
involved in that or sort of how did you
and if there were a lot how do you sort
of I know you guys have chemistry but
how do you that's electricity that is
right we were very strategic you know
some for some sequences I actually like
didn't want to see Naomi for a few days
so that the first time I saw her would
be on Sat or on camera
so I think for that sequence you know we
kind of planned not to see each other
for a few days so that we can bring that
authenticity to it I thought a princess
could go anywhere not this princess do
you trust me to know what it's like you
know that was my fault as well cuz I was
like cuz like before will was like you
know I'm gonna tell that story and I was
like oh my gosh and then like your
version no no it was kinda the same
version I mean I basically so guy has
this thing called black box alright
which is is before we shoots any movie
he basically runs the whole movie like
yeah weak base and it's so far it was so
funny because you're you won't you've
got teleprompters like you end up
laughing because it's just so but he
just wants to see it on its legs you
just wanted to kind of feel it it's it's
actually a really good idea yeah so it
got two speechless I'd recorded like a
demo version but no one had heard it so
you know I was like right here's what
you know really what I like do good even
though it's just like a black you know
rehearsal watching
yeah like everyone's watching so I went
for it and you know I was crying doing
the whole thing and then like you know
every well that's great and then we'll
you know he's walking up and I just met
him like not that long right all that so
he come is about it and he goes to high
five and and I did you know when you're
just crying you just go like that
like I
it's not like I had snore like he says
but and he literally was there and I
just I was a and I was a car and just
like if I bite him and we like look to
each other for a moment like are we
doing this we're gonna do it and then
the next day he was in the gym and I
thought I've got it I've got it
I can't not say that so I went up to me
on site so shall we talk about what
happened yesterday he was like oh yeah
and now it's like his favorite thing and
I sound like a weirdo but look if Will
Smith was walking up to you like I just
freaked out I didn't know what to do
right I five yeah what am I gonna do
like sorry well hold on a sec what
really nice Frank yeah I know exactly
but the funny thing was I was like you
know what I could have just used the
other hand extra yeah I find if I didn't
I love it I heard that growing up you
know you did get told you look like
Princess Jasmine but you said somewhere
in an interview that you used to play a
booth always I'd get really good how
does that ever eat out is that work how
do you pull because because you know
what it's like when you're a kid the
older girl always gets like the pig so I
just got ready to get to a booth like
but then again like I feel like I do
super what's your rendition of in a way
my definition of a rendition on my
rendition yeah oh my dad used to do this
to me love it I can't do it cuz I can do
my keyboards go oh you can okay so
that's like the Royal party no ma I was
trying to do that this specific Abu
thing which was like that you know like
we he does that thing yes
which actually don't worry about it that
doesn't sound like the monkey right nose
actually did last question is there
something from the original I know you
probably didn't want to watch it you
wanted to make it your own but what was
the essence of Jasmine that you kind of
took from the original and and brought
my personal experience with watching the
movie that's what I took
so what she meant to me I was like okay
I want to kind of still keep that
feeling and just the fact that she's
smart and she she can go toe-to-toe
like with someone you know if they're
trying it like when she first meet just
Prince Anders like she's witty as well
she's quick and she's kind of so I want
to definitely wanted to take that so
hopefully in the first moment you lock
eyes with a lad
that was electric to me watching it on
screen how many takes was that that was
I can't remember but Meena with his big
eyes what can you do if there's no
acting involved great ones and summons
me I stand by my oath loyalty two wishes
three I'm kidding Russia's
[Music]
this movie made me embrace a stranger
after the film ended the guy next to me
and I hugged really yes that was good it
was fantastic
I heard that the cast nicknamed you cry
Ritchie so what is this I think of you
as this tough guy this you know rock and
roll cold record I heard that you were
crying a lot on set well I can neither
confirm nor deny such accusations
there's something about my hearing
family film and particularly someone
like well that is kind of there's a
positive energy to these kind of things
these kind of productions and all those
everyone that was on board was in the
same vein that we all wanted to do to
make something that was I suppose
uncynical yeah and there really is a
deluge of positivity and I think that's
just inherent in the DNA of the
production but the casting was
phenomenal I mean it was so spot-on
it actually blew my mind everybody just
completely nailed it and I saw a lot of
behind the scenes footage and you were
smiling from ear-to-ear throughout and I
don't always see that with a director
and then you also called Will Smith
unlimitedly inspiring so can you speak
to that a little bit and sort of that
sort of sense of joy onset yeah I you
know my kids sort of dip them eventually
demanded that I should make a movie that
they could watch I heard that so in no
small part it was for them and they were
my yardstick my wife is a big Disney
file so I'm actually more familiar with
the world than you might think
but will so unlimited unlimitedly
generous yeah in in every sense really
he's not only is he very talented and
once you turn is tap on of creativity is
it again a deluge of positive gear that
you can extract from that and my job was
really just to encourage world to be
sort to be more well but then it
percolate percolates his way in all
sorts of other positive ways he was you
know a mentor towards meaner and no me
once he led the charge and he's
constantly positive you know they
followed and they didn't feel like they
were being judged
I give away at all and he sort of set
the pace and and everyone followed I saw
I'm you said in another interview that
after you and me to watch the screening
together you had a bit of a cuddle yeah
and I want to know first of all what are
your kids you said they were sort of the
yardstick and wanted you to make the
film what their reaction was and sort of
that moment watching it with the cast
funny my daughter was to two people down
from me
I mean er who I didn't know was about
ten people down from me on the other
side
my daughter dance from beginning to end
when she came yesterday it's quite fun
now though is that and she came dressed
as Princess Jasmine for the big from the
off so she was going to enjoy ourselves
well my daughter's seeing it more times
and I've seen it right
so she was she was in from there she has
all the songs and Mina well and myself
right when we sorted the premiere in
London a couple of garlic or they call
it we saw it a week ago a special and to
be fair that's the first time I've seen
it in its full incarnation right that's
always moving stuff around
you're watching reels you watching 20
minutes section yeah but actually watch
the whole thing mister first time it's
seen it and I have the memory of a
goldfish so I can never remember what
I've done and then when you watch the
whole thing in its entirety you go you
get sort of swept up in its positivity
and so Maynard never really seen it
before you know you see in part and then
I think it's you you you're not cynical
once you watch it as a whole thing you
get distracted by other aspects of the
business or whatever but actually when
you watch the production it's kind of
you remember why you did it and you
remember why you have this job and I
think Mina could got swept away in the
moment you know it and he could watch it
and let it wash over him and enjoy it
and they just want to say thanks if
you'll indulge me I have one gift for
you yeah but gift for you the last time
you were in Fandango yeah you asked for
a beer and we didn't have it we promised
the next interview and I know you have
your own brewery but I couldn't find guy
reaching here anywhere in the United
States so you told we have a Cheers we
can oh it's gonna be wool this is
exciting it's a blue moon beer it's the
closest there's nothing wrong with that
beer there really I thought it I I know
you're a beer connoisseur so I was like
I gotta pick one I don't know like it's
a Belgian beer
Cheers this is all terribly exciting one
of the greatest disney films i've ever
thank you
[Music]
first of all I was talking a little bit
to guy about the fact that everybody on
the set Nick renamed him cry Richie cuz
he cried a lot in the film then there
was a whole thing about Naomi
high-fiving Will Smith and she had yeah
yeah yeah you said you snot it on your
piano writing the song no I was joking I
was kidding you aren't so you don't cry
when you write songs ever or listen to
your own songs because we all day
occasionally but they went on for five
minutes at a press conference about this
not against your experience and I guess
said well yeah it's not fun you worked
you worked on the original Aladdin tell
me about the conception of some of those
original songs did they sort of come to
originally we were thinking we were
doing sort of an homage to The Hollywood
view of the mysterious East that was
kind of our wink so there was you know
very traditional
Middle Eastern music but then there's
you know what that's wallet for the
thieves or cab calloway friends Olli
body is he Ali Ababwa or don't hear or
of course a whole new world is just its
own thing but a very sort of lat
and then winch up heavy the breadline
one swing ahead of the sword and a rib
the riffraff Street red I don't buy that
and then we have this new song
speechless
I won't be silent you can't keep me
quiet we tremble when you try it all I
know is I won't go speechless so
together you know it says it's a score
and I know it holds together it does and
you never never had a friend like me so
to talk to me a little bit about how the
orig original song but then Will Smith's
take on it will brought a lot of hip-hop
to this rendition Oh madam so how did
you two sort of work together and how
did you find that hip hop he did really
he actually came to London to the first
run-through with that they recorded with
Matt Sullivan and Chris been set up my
team on the ground in London and they
just played it for me I went okay it's
sort of it's sort of done I mean yeah it
will made it his own and it's exactly
right
you know my original conception was
gonna pure fat swallow and then Robin
went to a whole you know his own place
and then will went to this oh my god
this is a credible place you've won
eight Oscars tell me your plate can you
play me your favorite song theyíve that
you've composed I can't I don't have a
favorite one of them oh god well the
puppy one where I didn't win an Oscar
which was safe behind these windows and
these parapets of stone from Hunchback
gazing at the people down below me all
my life I watch them as I hide up here
alone hungry for this Theresa show all
my life i memorize their faces
they will never know me all my life I
wonder how it feels to pass a day not
above them but margov and out there
living in my Oscar winning songs no it's
my favorite maybe
I don't know but I don't have favor
because they're all parts of mosaic and
they build a bigger picture to each you
know through the combination of the
songs
you